good morning Hank it's Friday a couple
things thing one in read your last video
it is not an anchoring bias to dismiss
the opinions of people who don't like
the mountain goats it's just a correct
aesthetic judgment Hank there are facts
in this world like the fact that my
singer Majid compositions are excellent
but inferior to Mozart and here's
another fact the mound goats are a great
band and yes my boys correct I'm angry
thing to Hank your video on Wednesday
reminded me of my favorite kind of bias
the denomination affect the denomination
affections the people are biased towards
spending money in small denominations
like we're more likely to spend 101
dollar bills than we are to spend 1 $100
bill it's also shown that across the
world people are biased towards spending
coins rather than spending paper money
although not American pennies of course
because no one spends American pennies
because they're worthless and evil you
want to talk about an anchoring bias
Hank I have an anchoring bias against
people who don't hate pennies so like
you know I hate pennies it's because
they cost more than a penny to make and
they also don't work as money because
they don't facilitate the exchange of
goods and services like try going to a
gas station and spending three hundred
eighty three pennies on a gallon of gas
lots of countries have eliminated their
pennies like the Netherlands has no
pennies and you know what happened
nothing inflation didn't go up
charitable contributions didn't go down
pennies are useless also if we got rid
of the penny you would save the
government millions of dollars a year
it's the kind of thing that you would do
if you were trying to say cut the budget
and you were serious about it instead of
just playing political games right I'm
getting distracted by my hatred of
pennies the denomination effect does not
apply to pennies but it applies to most
coins you know coins that have value
which brings me to the one dollar coin
Hank they're like a billion one dollar
coin sitting around the United States
but no one ever uses them because people
like paper money but the nonpartisan
Government Accountability Office
recently reported to Congress that if we
eliminated the one dollar bill and
introduced $1 and $2 coins we would save
5.5 billion dollars over the next 30
years billion with a B this is for two
reasons first it cost a lot of money to
print one dollar bills it now costs nine
point six cents per bill thanks to the
rising price of cotton and secondly the
average one dollar bill is only in
circulation for 40 months whereas the
average one dollar coin would be in
circulation for like 30 years and we
wouldn't even have to mint any new coins
because we already have a billion $1
coins that no one is using we just need
to remove the bills so that people have
to use them and if we did that people
might be slightly inconvenient for a
while though they seem to have gotten
used to it in Canada and
Europe but aside from saving the federal
government five billion dollars the
denomination effect tells us that people
would also spend more money and consumer
spending is the number one driver of
economic growth in America in short Hank
there are a lot of hard choices to make
but the denomination effect reminds us
that there are also some easy choices to
make and we aren't making them okay a
couple other things first nerdfighters
thank you so much for continuing to make
the Fault in Our Stars and best seller
on Amazon and Barnes & Noble I don't
even know what to say about that but
you're made of Awesome also I want to
thank nerdfighters Julie and Martha for
making will all pre-orders of The Fault
in Our Stars be signed calm my favorite
web site ever you'll find a link in the
doobly-doo it succinctly answers the
question I've been asked hundreds of
times this week speaking of which please
don't forget that you are deciding which
color sharpie I will use to sign these
books nerdfighters this is serious
business there is a link in the
doobly-doo to a poll in your pants is
not something that people say about
serious business no really I do want to
get the color right so vote oh and don't
forget to be the first six chapters of
the Great Gatsby by Wednesday I know you
don't come on YouTube for homework but
you just got some Hank I'll see you on
Monday